so Nintendo had their april fools
Nintendo Direct of course it wasn't
actually in april fools like all of it
was real i think one of the coolest
things that they were talking about that
we learned a lot more what were some
more amigo yeah what they're doing is
they're introducing you know new waves
right we've got you two and Lucas I know
you're excited about well we have those
continual waves that keep coming but we
we didn't know if those DLC characters
we're gonna have their own separate
amiibo so it's really exciting that you
two newly announced Lucas which oh my
god that's huge news to me because
mother three and then you know just
Nintendo poking that stick like oh yeah
you know I really thought they were
because they wouldn't follow that with
Virtual Console news I really thought
they were going to talk about that but
back to amigos what's interesting to me
is that they're sort of taking the form
factor that we all know and they're
they're adding to it so Yoshi's woolly
world that's gonna have three different
yoshimi bows that are actually made of
yarn there's no hard bass or anything
they do squishy little guys slightly
larger and just different colors
everything receive amiibo but the fact
that they're they're gonna be changing
the colors like that it is almost saying
like we know this is for you collectors
who just buy all these stupid things
like there's no reason you would just
get one there's going to be a meebo for
splatoon as well but the most
interesting evolution of the yummy bow
are the ones that they announced for the
Animal Crossing game that's coming
because they're in card form and they've
mentioned that this is something they
might do in the future either for amiibo
that have run out or just maybe in the
future this is how people will come out
in and that's actually what they're
doing instead of making individual
Animal Crossing amiibo you're gonna get
cards I don't know if I'm quite as
excited about that because you know the
appeal of a meebo is that they're little
toys that you can't get otherwise
sometimes the appeal of cards though is
that you buy them in a pack you don't
know what you're gonna get and so
therefore this is a whole mystery
involved and the excitement when you get
something great of course intendo makes
a lot of money if then I'm going to come
pet that road and I I see that
continuing be on animal crossing right
now lastly for me the thing that I guess
they announced before but the amoebas
now we'll be able to unlock little demo
as a game
to play the virtual console games only
right to play on the Wii U and not even
the full game you're gonna get access to
games you already have on Virtual
Console and for about what two minutes
three minutes it'll just be a short demo
it's kind of interesting that it's not
based on what the character is though
like you put down the Mario amiibo you
might not get Mario like you might not
get super mario brothers yeah that's
very interesting you think they would
associate those things together
naturally and and we asked a Nintendo
rep that we were talking to recently
about well is there a chance that you
might get the same demo twice across
different amigos they're not sure
hopefully there's a system in place to
prevent that but who knows we'll find
out oh and there's a lot of other news
to cover from the Nintendo Direct I
think one of the other cool parts is
that there's a whole new race mode being
added to mario kart 8 that we've never
had before ya know I'm really stoked
about that because I like mario kart 8
but I didn't get that great sense of
speed from it and so the new 200cc mode
is like exactly what I was asking for
you know like yes it's gonna be super
hard and difficult but at least I'll get
that sense of just you know it kind of
feels like watching it felt like I was
watching at zero you know and i think in
lieu of a new f-zero game hell I can
play some of the mario kart 8 tracks set
in the f0 universe on twenty-two CC and
that's pretty close another thing that
we learned about from the NASA no direct
is the codename steam it was it's a good
game it's a fun game from the fire love
team but it definitely had some problems
with pacing and it sounds like they're
gonna fix that yeah you have to watch
the enemy like you know take every turn
for every enemy that they have on the
map during a battle and that takes
forever and that was one of the biggest
complaints people had about the game
among others to be fair but Nintendo to
their credit has basically gone and
introduced a fast forward option so you
I think sort of like you do in all the
different me games on the 3ds and hold
down presumably gonna be like the right
trigger the left trigger speed things up
which is great because that's like
Nintendo listening to their fans doing
something about it quickly and doing it
in a way that just sort of totally
squashes that problem and it sounds like
if you have a new 3ds or even a better
reason to have the new 3ds is that you
can get through those even faster it's
you can't go quite as quickly on the
regular three dias I think it's two
times speed beyond on regular previous
and three times feed on the new
yes I mentioned this a little bit at the
beginning that Lucas is a fighter who's
coming to smash brothers which is
incredibly exciting for me you know
stoking that that earthbound fire which
it never dies inside me and I love that
they're introducing more characters but
South Korea had said earlier that we
might not get any more DLC at all for
smash brothers that's not going to be
the case at all though maybe he wish
that was the case because it was so
tired but one of the things I wada
announced was that they're going to be
doing a online voting system where
people can just can cast their vote for
what characters they want to be in the
new smash a little reason why and
obviously they're not gonna be able to
get everything that everyone suggests
but what a great move from Nintendo and
like another example of them listening
to their fans you know like and where so
many companies fail to do that they're
going out of their way basically saying
like qasim do you guys pretty much just
speak with your votes you know let us
know and we'll make it happen if we can
and the final one on our list is the
virtual console is gonna be beefed up a
little bit more gonna get some n64 and
Nintendo DS games it's getting a whole
lot of beef but more interesting thing
is how they're gonna be able to tweak
the controls in that though yeah you're
gonna be able to completely map any
button on the 64 to a button on the
gamepad that you wish and as for the DS
games what's interesting is they give
you three different ways to play them in
three different ways for the wii u to
present them so you can play them on the
gamepad by holding it vertically you get
the top of the bottom screen you can
play some games using the TV for the top
screen of the d/s and then the gamepad
for the bottom screen obviously or you
can have it beyond just the TV as well
which I guess the game that doesn't
require touch should I be fine with I'd
be curious if they're gonna mirror
between the gamepad and that TV just so
you can kind of get the best of both
worlds but it's a pretty sweet move I
mean it kind of its it's made sense
forever that they should do this and
they said that they're going to do it so
it's great to kind of see it happen
finally and they list out a few of the
games that will be getting which nothing
super crazy super exciting it'll be more
interesting when we figure out what
happens with between that DNA merger and
bringing then a club nintendo and all
that together and eventually maybe
having a virtual console that marries
your handheld and your console
you